Voy a darles cuatro ejemplos concretos, que retomaré al final,
acerca de como una empresa llamada "Silk" triplicó sus ventas realizando una sola cosa.
Como un artista llamado Jeff Koons paso de ser un don nadie
a ganar una gran pila de dinero y tener un gran impacto,
como Frank Gehry redefinió el concepto de lo que significa ser un arquitecto.
Y uno de mis peores fracasos, en los últimos años, como profesional del marketing,
una discográfica que fundé que tuvo un CD llamado "Salsa".
Antes de contarles todo lo anterior, tengo que contarles sobre el pan lactal, y un hombre llamado Otto Rohwedder.
Antes que el pan lactal fuera creado, alrededor de la década del 10
Me pregunto que dirían en ese momento....
algo como: "el mayor invento desde el telégrafo o desde alguna cosa".
Pero este hombre, llamado Otto Rohwedder creó el pan lactal,
y se concentró, como todo inventor, en dos cuestiones: la patente y el proceso.
Y lo significativo acerca de la creación del pan lactal es que...
durante los primeros 15 años que el pan lactal estuvo a la venta
nadie lo compro, nadie oyó nada acerca de él. Fue un completo y total fracaso.
Y la razón es que hasta que la empresa Wonder llegó
e inventó una forma para propagar la idea del pan lactal, nadie lo quería.
Ese es el triunfo en el pan lactal,
como el triunfo en casi todas las cuestiones que vamos a hablar en esta charla,
no siempre se trata de como es la patente, o como es la fábrica,
es acerca si uno es capaz de propagar una idea o no.
Y creo que la manera en que se puede conseguir lo que se quiere,
o hacer que el cambio que se quiera crear ocurra,
es darse cuenta cual es el modo de difundir las ideas.
Y no me importa a que se dedica cada uno, si están a cargo de un café,
o son un intelectual, o un empresario, o se dedican a hacer volar globos aerostáticos.
Creo que todo esto se aplica a cualquiera sin importar a que nos dedicamos.
Que lo que estamos viviendo es un siglo de difusión de ideas.
Que las personas puedan propagar sus ideas, sin importar cuales son esas ideas, y ganar.
Generalmente cuando hablo de este tema, elijo a los negocios
porque tienen las mejores imágenes que se pueden poner en una presentación,
y porque es la manera más fácil de llevar la puntuación.
Pero quisiera que me perdonen por usar estos ejemplos
porque estoy hablando de cualquier cosa en la que decidan gastar su tiempo.
En el centro de la propagación de ideas se puede encontrar a la televisión y cosas como la televisión.
la televisión y los medios masivos hacen, de algún modo, realmente fácil la difusión de ideas.
Yo lo llamo el complejo industrial televisivo.
El complejo industrial televisivo funciona de esta manera:uno compra publicidad,
interrumpe a algunas personas, y así obtenes distribución.
La distribución que conseguís la usas para vender más productos.
Tomas la ganancia de eso y compras más publicidad.
Y esto empieza de vuelta una y otra vez,
de la misma manera que funcionaban los complejos militares e industriales hace mucho tiempo.
Y ese modelo, del cual oimos ayer,
si solo pudieramos llegar a la pagina principal de Google,
si solo pudieramos averiguar como publicitarnos alli,
si solo pudieramos acogotar a esa persona,
y explicarles que queremos hacer.
Si hicieramos eso todo el mundo nos prestaria atencion y entonces podriamos obtener lo que queremos.
Este complejo industrial televisivo me saturó de información durante toda mi niñez y problamente la tuya tambien.
Quiero decir, que todos estos productos triunfaron porque alguien se dio cuenta
de cómo influir en las personas de un modo que ellas no esperaban,
de un modo que ellas no querían, con un aviso publicitario,
una y otra vez hasta que lo compraban.
Y lo que paso fue que cancelaron el complejo industrial televisivo.
Y eso solo en los últimos años,
lo que cualquiera que hace marketing descubrió
es: ya nada funciona como solía funcionar.
Disculpen por la foto que está confusa, es que tenía una tremenda gripe cuando la saqué.
Pero el producto que se ve en la caja azul del medio es mi mejor ejemplo.
Exacto. Voy a la tienda, estoy enfermo, necesito comprar algunos remedios.
El gerente de esa marca gasta en en ese producto azul 100 millones de dólares
al año tratando de interrumpirme.
100 millones de dólares interrumpiendome con publicidades televisivas y avisos publicitarios en revistas y en mails
y cupones de descuento y obteniendo mucho espacio en las estanterias de los supermercados y comisiones por venta -
y a pesar de todo esto, puedo elegir ignorar cada mensaje.
Y entonces ignoro cada mensaje, porque los remedios para el dolor de cabeza no significan un problema para mí.
Yo compro lo que viene en la caja amarilla porque siempre lo hice así.
Y no pienso invertir ni un minuto de mi tiempo en resolver su problema,
porque sencillamente no me interesa.
Esta es una revista llamada "Hidratate". Son 180 páginas que hablan de agua.
(Risas)
Exacto. Artículos sobre agua, publicidad sobre agua.
Imagínense el mundo como era hace 40 años
cuando solo existian el diario "Saturday Evening Post" y las revistas "Time" y "Newsweek".
Hoy existen revistas cuyo tema es el agua.
Nuevos productos de Coca-Cola de Japón, ensalada de agua.
(Risas)
Está bien. Coca-Cola de Japón saca a la venta un nuevo producto cada tres semanas.
Porque no tienen idea que es lo que va a funcionar y que no.
No podria haberlo escrito yo mejor. Salió hace cuatro días,
redondee las partes importantes para que las puedan ver.
Publicaron que "Arby" va a gastar 85 millones de dólares para promocionar una manopla para el horno
que viene con la voz de Tom Arnold,
esperando que eso haga que la gente vaya a Arby a comprar un sandwich de carne asada.
(Risas)
Ahora, yo he tratado de imaginarme que puede tener un comercial televisivo
protagonizado por Tom Arnold, que te haga meterte en tu auto,
manejar a traves de la ciudad y comprar un sanwich de carne asada.
(Risas)
Este es Copérnico, y el tenía razón,
cuando le hablaba a cualquiera que quisiera escuchar su idea.
El mundo da vueltas alrededor mío. Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo. Mi persona preferida, yo.
No quiero recibir más mails, quiero recibir "yo-mails".
(Risas)
Es por eso que los consumidores, y no me refiero solo a las personas que compran cosas en Safeway (de manera prudente),
me refiero a las personas en el Ministerio de Defensa que compren algo,
o las personas en el "New Yorker" que pueden imprimir tu artículo.
Vos no le importás a los consumidores, sencillamente no les importa.
Y parte de la razón, es que tienen muchas más ofertas de las que tenían,
y muchisimo menos tiempo.
Y en un mundo en el que se ofrecen tantas opciones
y tan poquito tiempo, lo lógico es sencillamente ignorar las cosas.
Mi parábola acá es ésta: estás manejando por la ruta
y ves una vaca, y seguis manejando
porque ya has visto vacas antes.
Las vacas son invisibles. Las vacas son aburridas.
Quien va a parar, acercarse y decir: "Uy, miren, una vaca." Nadie.
(Risas)
Pero si la vaca fuera violeta, ¿no sería ese un tremendo efecto especial?
Puedo hacer eso de vuelta si quieren.
Si la vaca fuera violeta, te asombrarías por un rato.
Quiero decir, si todas las vacas fueran violetas, te aburririas de esas tambien.
Lo que hará que se decida de que se habla,
que se hace, que cambia,
qué se compra, qué se contruye,
es, es esto notable?
Y notable, es una palabra interesante porque significa elegante,
pero también significa, algo que lo que vale la pena hacer una nota (comentario).
Y es esto la esencia de hacia donde esta yendo la expansión de las ideas.
Esos, son dos de los autos más deseados en los Estados Unidos, es un auto gigantesco de 55.000 doláres,
suficientemente grande como para guardar un Mini Cooper en su baúl.
La gente está pagando todo lo que cuestan por cada uno, y lo único que tienen en común
es que no tienen nada en común.
(Risas)
Todas las semanas el DVD mas vendido en Estados Unidos cambia.
Nunca es ni "El Padrino", ni "Ciudadano Kane",
Siempre es una película de tercera clase con alguna personalidad de segunda clase.
Pero la razón es que es la numero uno, porque esa es la semana que salió a la venta.
Porque es nueva, porque está fresca.
Porque la gente la vio y dijo, "No sabía que eso existía",
y se dieron cuenta.
Dos de los casos de mayor gloria de los últimos veinte años en ventas al por menor,
uno vende un producto extremadamente caro en una caja azul,
y el otro vende un producto que es tan barato como lo puede hacer.
Lo unico que tienen en común es que son diferentes.
Estamos en el negocio de la moda, no importa cual sea nuestra profesión,
estamos en la industria de la moda.
Y la cosa es que, la gente en la industria de la moda
sabe como es trabajar en la industria de la moda, porque están acostumbrados a eso.
El resto de nosotros debe descifrar como pensar de esa manera.
Como entender que no es cuestion de interrumpir a la gente con grandes avisos de una página,
o seguir insistiendo en reunirse con la gente.
Sino que es un proceso totalmente diferente el que determina que ideas se propagan,
y cuales no.
Esta silla, se vendieron sillas Aeron por un valor de un billón de dólares
reinventando el concepto de lo que es vender una silla.
Convirtieron a la silla, de algo que adquiría el departamento de compras,
a algo que es un símbolo de estatus acerca de donde te sentas para trabajar.
Lionel Poullain, este hombre, es el panadero más famoso del mundo,
se murió hace dos meses y medio,
fue un ídolo para mí y un gran amigo.
Vivía en Paris. El año pasado vendió pan francés por un valor de 10 millones de doláres.
Cada hogaza era cocinada en su propia panadería, por un panadero a la vez, en un horno de leña.
Y cuando Lionel comenzo su panadería, los franceses lo escupían.
No querían comprar su pan. No se parecía en nada al pan francés.
No era lo que esperaban.
Era elegante, era notable, y despacito se propagó de persona en persona,
hasta que se convirtió finalmente en el pan oficial de los restaurantes de tres estrellas de Paris.
Ahora se instaló en Londres y hace envios via FedEx a todo el mundo.
Lo que la gente que se dedica a comercialización hacía era fabricar productos promedio para gente promedio.
Eso es comercialización a gran escala.
Alisa los bordes, y ve por el centro,
ahí está el gran mercado.
Ignoraban a los "geeks"
y Dios no lo permita, también a los rezagados.
Estaba todo abocado a ir por el centro.
Pero en un mundo en donde el complejo industrial televisivo está arruinado,
no creo que esa sea una estrategia que queramos seguir usando
Creo que la estrategia que queremos usar es no venderle a esas personas
porque son realmente buenas ignorándote.
Pero si tratar de venderle a estas personas porque les importa.
Estas son las personas que están obsesionadas con algo.
Y cuando les hablas, te van a escuchar
porque les gusta escuchar, les estás hablando de ellos.
Y si tenés suerte, le van a contar a sus amigos
del resto de la curva, y se va a propagar.
Se va a propagar a toda la curva.
Tienen algo que yo llamo "otaku", es una gran palabra japonesa.
Describe el deseo de alguien que esta obsesionado, de manera tal que
maneja a través de todo Tokio para comer en un nuevo lugar que sirven fideos ramen,
porque eso es lo que les gusta hacer. Se obsesionaron con eso.
Para fabricar un producto, para comercializar una idea,
para que aparezca un problema que queres resolver
eso no se circunscribe con un "otaku",
es casi imposible.
Por el contrario, tenes que encontrar un grupo que realmente,
desesperadamente le interese lo que vos tenes para decir.
Hablales y haceles fácil el contarles a sus amigos.
Existe una salsa picante "otaku", pero no existe una mostaza "otaku".
Por eso existen montones y montones de diferentes tipos de salsa picante,
y no tantos tipos distintos de mostaza.
No es dificil hacer una mostaza interesante
-es posible hacer una mostaza interesante-
pero la gente no se obsesiona con ella,
y por lo tanto no le cuentan a sus amigos.
"Krispy Kreme" ha descifrado todo esto.
"Krispy Kreme" tiene una estrategia, esto es lo que hacen,
entran a una ciudad, le hablan a la gente con "otaku",
y luego se propagan a través de la ciudad
a la gente que acaba de cruzar la calle.
Este yoyó cuesta 112 dólares, pero duerme durante 12 minutos.
No lo quiere todo el mundo, pero no les importa.
Quieren hablarle a la gente que lo quiere, y asi tal vez se propagué.
Estos chicos hacen el estereo para auto más ruidoso del mundo.
(Risas)
Es tan ruidoso como un avión 747, no podés meterte
el auto tiene blindex en las ventanas
porque sino explotaría el parabrisas.
Pero el hecho es que cuando alguien
quiera poner unos parlantes en su auto,
si tienen "otaku"
o escucharon de alguien que lo tiene,
van a ir para adelante y elegir esto.
Es realmente muy sencillo, vos vendes al que te está escuchando
y quizás, sólo quizás esas personas le cuentan a sus amigos.
Entonces cuando Steve Jobs se dirige a 50.000 personas en su conferencia,
que están todos conectados desde 130 países
mirando su publicidad de dos horas--
eso es lo único que hace que su empresa siga en el negocio--
eso es lo único que a esas 50.000 personas les interesa lo suficiente como para desesperarse
para ver un comercial de dos horas, y contarles a sus amigos.
"Pearl Jam", 96 discos lanzados en los últimos dos años.
Todos tuvieron su ganancia. ¿Cómo?
Solamente los vendieron en su página de internet.
Quienes lo compraron en su página de internet tienen "otaku",
y entonces le cuentan a sus amigos, y se propaga y se propaga.
Esta cuna para hospital cuesta 10.000 dólares, 10 veces más que una estándar.
Pero los hospitales la están adquiriendo más rápido que cualquier otro modelo.
El esmalte para uñas "Hard Candy" no le gusta a todo el mundo,
pero a la gente que lo ama, habla como loca de él.
Esta lata de pintura de acá salvó a la empresa de pintura "Dutch Boy",
haciéndoles ganar una fortuna. Cuesta un 35% más que una pintura común
porque "Dutch Boy" hizo una lata de la cual la gente habla, porque es extraordinaria.
No se remitieron a abofetearnos con una nueva publicidad del producto,
cambiaron el significado de lo que significa fabricar un producto de pintura.
Amlhotornot.com (estoybuenoono.com)-- todos los días reciben 250.000 visitas,
dirigida por dos voluntarios, que yo puedo contarles de su exigencia a la hora de dar su veredicto, y
(Risas)
no llegaron a esto publicitando mucho.
Llegaron, siendo extraordinarios,
a veces un poco demasiado extraordinarios.
Y este marco fotográfico tiene un cable que va hacia atrás,
y lo pones en un enchufe en la pared.
Mi papá tiene uno de estos en su escritorio,
y ve todos los días a sus nietos, cambiando a cada rato.
Y cada una de las personas que entra a su oficina
escucha todo el cuento de como esta cosa terminó en su escritorio.
Y una persona a la vez, esta idea se propaga.
Estos no son realmente diamantes.
Están hechos de cenizas humanas.
Después que tu cuerpo es cremado podés hacer que te conviertan en una joya.
(Risas)
Ah, les gusta mi anillo? Es mi abuela
El negocio con más rápido crecimiento en toda la industria funeraria.
Pero no tienes que ser Ozzie Osborne
no tienes que ser provocador para hacer esto.
Lo que tenés que hacer es descifrar qué quiere la gente y dárselos.
Un par de reglas rápidas para resumir.
La primera es: el diseño es gratis cuando lo llevas a escala.
Y a la gente se le ocurren cosas extraordinarias
con más frecuencia que no, se le ocurre un modo de poner el diseño a trabajar para ellas
Segundo: Lo más arriesgado que podés hacer hoy es ser prudente.
"Procter and Gamble" sabe esto, ¿verdad?
Todo el modelo acerca de ser "Procter and Gamble"
se basa en productos promedio para gente promedio.
Eso es arriesgado. Lo prudente hoy, es estar en los límites,
ser extraordinario.
Y ser muy bueno es una de las peores cosas que podés hacer.
Ser muy bueno es aburrido. Ser muy bueno es mediocre.
No importa si estás armando un album discográfico,
o sos un arquitecto, o tenés un tratado en sociología.
Si es muy bueno, no va a funcionar, porque nadie lo va a notar.
Ahora si, mis tres historias.
"Silk". Coloca un producto que no necesita estar en la gondola refrigerada del supermercado
al lado de la leche ubicada en la góndola refrigerada.
Se triplican las ventas. ¿Por qué?
Leche, leche, leche, leche, leche -- algo que no es leche.
Para quien estuviera allí mirando esa góndola,
fue extraordinario.
No triplicaron sus ventas con publicidad,
las triplicaron haciendo algo extraordinario.
Esta es una obra de arte extraordinaria. No tiene porque gustarte,
pero un perro de 40 pies de alto hecho de arbustos
en la mitad de la ciudad de Nueva York es extraordinario.
Frank Gehry no sólo modificó un museo,
cambió la economía de toda una ciudad
diseñando una construcción que gente de todo el mundo fuera para verla.
Hoy en día, en un sinfin de reuniones, ustedes sabrán,
en la municipalidad de la ciudad de Portland, quién sabe dónde,
dicen, necesitamos un arquitecto, podremos conseguir a Frank Gehry?
Porque él hizo algo que estuvo al límite.
¿Y mi gran fracaso? Saqué todo un
(Música)
albúm discográfico y ojalá toda una serie de albumes discográficos
en formato SACD - este extraordinario nuevo formato -
y lo comercializé directamente a personas con estéreos de 20.000 dólares.
A personas con estéreos de 20.000 dólares no les interesa la música nueva.
(Risas)
Entonces lo que hay que descifrar es a quien le interesa que cosa.
Quién es el que va a levantar la mano y decir,
"Yo quiero saber que vas a hacer después",
y venderles a ellos.
El último ejemplo que les doy.
Este es un mapa del Lago "Soap" en Washington.
Como ven, si eso es la nada, se encuentra ahí en el medio.
(Risas)
Pero si tienen un lago.
Y las personas hacían miles de millas para nadar al lago.
No lo hacen más. Entonces los padres fundadores dijeron: "Tenemos un poco de plata para gastar.
¿Qué podemos construir acá?". Y como en la mayoria de las comisiones,
estaban por construir algo bastante prudente.
Y entonces un artista llegó - esta es una verdadera reproducción del artista-
y quiso construir una lámpara de lava de 55 pies de alto en el medio de la ciudad.
Eso es una vaca violeta, eso es algo que vale la pena prestarle atención
No sé ustedes, pero si la construyen, ese es el lugar al que voy a ir.
Muchas gracias a todos por su atención.